this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Gaurav for the introduction
and for the opportunity to come back to
Cornell I was here I guess about twelve
years ago and I had quite an experience
as some of you know I went to a frat
party I was here as an invited speaker
and we didn't go last night so I'm but
they're still tonight not going home
until tomorrow morning
and what else did I want to say yeah
just a couple of things so yeah if you
want to ask questions I think two good
questions maybe that I won't get into
right now but good questions to ask are
how did you get into this there's always
a story I don't look for trouble but
trouble finds me all the time how did
you get into this and then secondly you
know what's it like being an
entrepreneur I will say that I did get
into science to try to avoid
entrepreneurs and and business people
and and especially lawyers but it's not
really working out very well and I can
tell you all kinds of stories as to why
all right so let's say so this is this
actually could have been a picture from
our dinner last night kind of but it's
actually a painting of Friedrich sare
Turner who was a pharmacist's apprentice
and back in the early 1800s in 1804 1806
he was the first to isolate a natural
product from a plant and it was morphine
from from opium poppy I'm not sure
exactly what he's doing here it's kind
of a strange way of going drinking with
your buddies and he's definitely caused
some problems for them over here but
we'll get we'll get back to that in just
a moment I'm gonna start with
acknowledgments because I always leave
it to the end and then I run out of time
and and I don't feel like I give enough
credit to the people that are in the lab
presently and certainly those that have
been in my lab previously I think I
think it sounds like you met at
one of them recently so I'm gonna start
with the the company so we have this
startup Gaurav was was referring to is
called a pin Ron incorporated it's in
the process of expanding and and
hopefully bigger things are happening
some very high caliber scientists it's
great working with very senior people
because I just sort of say do this we
need to do this and then they go in and
they do it I still have a small academic
lab with a couple of postdocs in and two
to PhD students and then and then some
collaborators and get lots of funding or
over the years lots of funding from
especially Canadian government federal
sources and more recently having the
company has provided a good means of
combining sort of industrial
applications and translation of research
with continued and continued academic
quests and and being able to support a
lot of those quests so I just wanted to
say a little bit more about about the
company I I do enjoy being part of you
know the entrepreneurial experience so
we started this company in in 2014 and
again you know I think I'd be happy to
share with you experiences as to why I
wasn't quite happy with the trends
translational capabilities at the
University of Calgary they mean well but
they don't have the capital to to really
move a lot of these technologies from
the state that they're at to something
that's going to be of interest to to a
bigger multinational especially
pharmaceutical companies out there so we
started decided to try to do it
ourselves and we currently have eight
full-time staff members and our business
model so far has not been so our
intention is not actually to produce
opiates in yeast fermentation but it's
to do this and that's to basically use
our knowledge of the system and find the
new parts understand the processes and
then move those discoveries and
intellectual property to intermediate
and and larger partners that are able to
take it all
to Italy to to market so we we generate
a lot of IP a lot of patents and we
license those patents and one of our
biggest partners so far has been in
treks on which has found a few locations
across the u.s. so we collaborated with
one of their their units that's in San
Francisco all right so so I'll get get
to the star of the show which is opium
poppy so opium poppy is a ancient
medicinal plant it's being cultivated
domesticated by a number of
civilizations around the world for about
the last six or seven thousand years and
in spite of its age and how long that
we've been connected
we've been connected to it it's still
our only source for all of the compounds
that you see on this slide so morphine
and codeine are natural compounds in the
plant nos Kapena and papaverine are also
they also have pharmaceutical
applications as a cough suppressant
papaverine is a vasodilator and nos
caffeine is also being investigated for
potential anti-cancer properties it
hasn't made it past phase two clinical
trials yet but also very importantly are
these semi synthetic compounds oxycodone
hydrocodone and especially these days
you hear a lot about naloxone as an
antagonist so it's used it's very
effective at treating overdose so
there's you can go to pharmacies I don't
know what the situation is like in the
US but in in Canada you can go to a
pharmacy and they'll give you an A
Locke's own kit basically with surrett
in it so if somebody's overdosing from
fentanyl or whatever on on the you know
on the the subway you can have that and
and you can save their lives in in many
cases by having this available so these
compounds are semi synthetic the
backbone comes from the plant and I'll
tell you more about that shortly but
then they are modified through through
some chemical processes to get these
additional functional groups on there
all right so so again I like to start
with I like to connect with with these
plants in the sense of why they're
important to humanity and this is a
plant that we've had a long relationship
is in with as humans and you can see
that evidence in archaeological
discoveries especially all through
Europe and and the Middle East so these
are locations where there's been some
sort of opium poppy artifact that often
goes back to the Bronze Age you know so
it's so three four thousand years BC you
find these poppy capsules and in various
artifacts this cave of the bats here in
in Spain is one of the prime locations
where you find these these materials and
I was talking last night about how
interested I am one day when I'm you
know wealthy enough not now but to to
get my hands on some of this material
and and do some ancient DNA sequencing
and see what those see what those poppy
varieties were like and try to trace you
know how did this plant get around how
did how did people move it around and
connect that anthropologically with with
the history with our history as you know
as as humans ancient empires are all
connected with with opium poppies so
there's a bunch of them listed here and
you can see it again in archaeological
artifacts so opium poppy on these Roman
coins or Greek coins this is a accretion
poppy goddess you know and you often see
again on these reliefs the depictions of
opium poppy being associated with
ancient civilizations what's interesting
is that in Europe even though opium
poppy goes back many thousands of years
the knowledge of the plant and the
medicinal compounds in Europe at least
was lost from about the fall of the
Roman Empire until the Renaissance
so nobody nobody used it or had it
anymore in Europe it was brought back
knowledge was actually maintained in in
other parts of the world so in the Arab
world or in in Persia
and brought back to Europe and was
brought back by this fellow over here
and his name is Paracelsus so Paracelsus
was an interesting person a Renaissance
botanist Alchemist physician astrologer
and a cultist I'd like to put that on my
business card and you know an
interesting job description so he was
traveling in Arabia and he brought back
a sword if it's on a magic card or
whatever you know it's important so you
know he brought back a sword and in the
in the hilt of the sword there was there
were these crystals that were that he
called the stones of immortality so it
was opium citrus system citrus juice and
gold's basically mixed together in some
nuggets and you know from that point it
became again part of sort of European
medical culture in during the
Renaissance and things really got
interesting in the 1800s so so in the
1800s opium started to be used much more
extensively it's actually a very
dangerous time apparently to be a child
during during that but that part of time
in history so you can see that from some
of these ads over here mrs. Winslow's
soothing syrup for children teething you
know cough killer it works like magic so
as someone that has had children I think
those of you that also do would probably
agree with me that it's unfortunate that
these products are no longer available
because I can imagine they were they
were quite effective at kind of keeping
kids quiet it was also you know opiates
were actually a very big part of the
American Civil War so there was an awful
lot of addiction because all soldiers
were given as a syringe and an opium for
their their bad of battlefield wounds
and and again it's a-you know I to have
these kind of connections or
understanding of a plant that has such
an ancient origin and how it's connected
to so much of our history makes you know
the trials and tribulations of pipetting
in a lab along
more enjoyable when you know that you're
contributing to that to that history so
it continues to be a plant that is a
dual use technology so you can use it
for both good and and bad purposes but
most of our technologies are like that
right nuclear nuclear power nuclear
energy is a good example of that you can
generate electricity or you can do the
wrong things with with with that that
same technology so so here's the here's
the dark side of opium poppy so if you
forget everything else from this talk
you'll remember this and and that's what
happens when you take morphine that's
extracted from the plant and you mix it
together with an acetyl donor so you can
buy some acetic anhydride that is
actually quite difficult to buy because
you can do this with it you can make
morphine to acetate prettily pretty
easily and morphine diacetate of course
is heroin and then you can see the
difference all that's happening is that
the morphine is being died acetylide at
those two hydroxyl functions and it was
back in the early part of the 20th
century that that heroin was used
extensively as a cost suppressant so
there's some ads from some old some old
products the problem of cough has been
solved by by heroin and certainly it's
very effective just like codeine is
effective as a cough cough medicine it
was believed that this product heroin
was non addictive and certainly that
wasn't true so within you know some few
years of it being put on the market
there were half a million opium addict
or heroin addicts in the US and then in
the 1920s he was taken off the market as
a cough suppressant but of course it
remains as as a problem in the world and
and this kind of demonstrates the the
problem the problem is you can make
money from from producing heroin so you
can you know you can grow opium poppy in
Afghanistan and then you can transport
the opium to other countries like Turkey
and add value to it with some degree of
processing and then by the time you get
it to to Europe on the streets as heroin
heroin you've added a lot of value to to
the product and just gives you some idea
you know where the problems are
particularly bad um in in Europe in
Russia and other parts parts of the
world not not really so much in North
America in Canada it's Vancouver that
has the biggest problem with with
opiates and and heroin addiction and
other other places what I hear is
Calgary is too cold so nobody wants to
kind of live on the streets in Calgary
that's probably a bad idea actually
in the winter so this is my map of what
I call the good guys and the bad guys
sort of thing so so the good guys are in
green and and it's not really quite
accurate but the the problems in the
world are in red the biggest problem of
course is Afghanistan for illicit
production of of opium poppy Mexico and
Colombia are counting now for maybe
about five percent of the total illicit
production the golden triangle over here
used to be more of a problem a lot less
so recently um but what's interesting is
all these countries in green that are
actually illicit producers illicit
growers of opium poppy Australia is
number one maybe I'm being a little bit
unfair to the Australians by suggesting
that their entire continent is a haven
for growing opium poppy it's actually
restricted just to the island of
Tasmania but they account for about 50%
of the global licit production right now
but also other countries India Turkey
and even France and in particular in
Europe account for a substantial France
easily ten percent of illicit production
and it's done in very modern ways okay
so it's it's here's a poppy field in
Tasmania using modern farming equipment
the plants have - as required by the
United Nations they have to be allowed
to dry in the field and then the the
harvester comes along basically cuts
them off with about ten centimeters of
stem and then takes that material
crushes it and extracts the the
pharmaceutical products of interest the
traditional way of collecting opium
poppy of course is to Lance the unripe
seed capsules and this latex will exude
and the latex once it dries and oxidizes
becomes raw opium so the content
of morphine at this stages maybe 1% or
under 1% of the of the liquid but when
it oxidizes and dries and because this
loaf of raw opium it will rise to about
15% of the of the weight all right so
it's a lot easier to ship this material
illicitly around as opposed to all of
this biomass and that's the reason the
UN only allows India in fact to continue
in an illicit manner to do it this way
because it's it's considered to be
historical or traditional so this guy
over here is interesting to me because
he's he's doing his job and you can see
without the use of gloves so I'm sure
that his job satisfaction rating is
higher than mine ever will be that
doesn't say much on many days so so
again connecting to the scientific
history of everything you're going to
hear today so I think you know I think
one of the things that I try to impress
on students is is that you know what we
know what's in the textbook or what what
you read in the literature and and we
discuss as now the dogma in the field
somebody had to get us to that point
many people get us to that point and
it's a very long and slow process so
this is a timeline of of morphine for
morphine 200 years more than 200 years
of scientific history from ser Turner
and his first isolation of morphine to
30 25 years later the isolation of
codeine by this this French chemist
heroin was first synthesized in 1874 the
structure of morphine was not determined
until 1925 you know almost a hundred and
25 years later after the compound was
isolated the structure was identified
and it was it was identified by this
fellow here I'm Sir Robert Robertson who
was a Nobel Prize winner and also
knighted as is his this this fellow is
still alive Alan Battersby brought the
biochemistry forward they're both both
sirs
even though Canada is still part of the
Commonwealth I'm not allowed to become a
sir because I'm not a British subject
so I didn't put my picture over here I
just put a bit of the pathway maybe
later so yeah lots of lots of lots of
interesting and and important
discoveries but a very long period of
time and this is the period of time that
we're operating in and about the last
quarter of a century okay so so I want
to show you now how a plant how opium
poppy the only plant that we kicked that
can really do it how it can make
morphine from tyrosine so this elegance
is really impressive how do you take a
simple amino acid two copies of it and
and make this molecule that chemists can
make but they really can't yet make it
at yields that are economically
competitive with using the plant as a
source of these compounds so let's let's
just start off then with tyrosine and
the way I like to show this I don't like
to show slides that have lots of
structures all over the place I actually
came up with this some years ago I was
stuck in the airport in Boston overnight
and I didn't know what to do they shut
everything down so I basically drew
structures what else does a biochemistry
on your board I think this is an
effective way of showing it so there's
tyrosine the first thing that happens is
it's decarboxylated and then it's three
hydroxylated so you end up with dopamine
it's important narrow transmitter in US
but it's also a precursor to morphine
and opium poppy there's another molecule
of tyrosine and this time going down
this route over here you deaminate it
and then you decarboxylate it and you
end up with the second intermediate that
combines with tyrosine with dopamine to
make the first so called benzyl
isoquinoline alkaloid and this is four
hydroxy phenyl acetaldehyde
okay so there they are again dopamine
and four hydroxy phenyl acetaldehyde or
four HPA and you get a pictage Spangler
condensation reaction catalyzed by this
enzyme there Cochrane synthase and there
you go now you have a benzyl
isoquinoline alkaloid it's benzyl
isoquinoline because there's the benzyl
and there's the isoquinoline moiety and
that's it's as simple as that
it doesn't retain that structural form
the backbone structure changes and so
too does the decoration so any every
time you change the backbone structure
of one of these benzyl isochronal and
alkaloids you have a whole new molecule
that you can decorate with different
functionalities and change its the
pharmacological properties biological
properties and so on
of the molecule so let's start off with
this nor Cochran over here so it's it's
6o methylated and then n methylated
three prime hydroxyl Aidid and then four
prime ho methylated that's these
reactions over here and you end up with
this key intermediate called
s reticulating we were talking this
morning at breakfast about chirality so
it's an it's in the S it's the s
conformer of reticulan and what's
interesting is that that wasn't good
enough apparently for opium poppy it it
wouldn't it is unable to drive it
forward to morphine as the s conformer
it has to change to the our conformer
has to change his right hand to its left
hand something like maybe the left hand
or the right hand and and this is what
happens next
okay so so there's um there's s
reticulate and how do you how do you
change the chirality of a chiral Center
you can remove it by oxidizing it and
then you can put it back by reducing it
that's just the specificity of these of
these two enzymes which interestingly
have fused together into a single enzyme
that we call particularly an epimer ace
and it simply changes the handedness of
the intermediate so let's look at
reticulating that those are actually the
same two compounds over there just
changing the perspective of how we're
looking at it it's easier to look at it
this way because the next step in the
process is to change the structure the
backbone structure and that's done by
this enzyme here salutary teen synthase
there's salutary teen a carbon-carbon
coupling and you have now a four
membered ring and you can start to
decorate it again so it's it is reduced
to from the keto to the to the alcohol
and then the the
the hydroxyl group is Isetta lated and
then that allylic group falls off and
you end up with fee bein now you have
your Penta cyclic backbone and from
there you have now another somewhat
different backbone structure and you can
continue to change the functionalities
so it's six OD methylated reduced three
OD methylated and now you have morphine
but very elegant process every one of
those steps catalyzed by a different
enzyme and now you know every one of
those genes encoding those enzymes is
available to do something with to study
and so on okay so um what I want to talk
to you mostly about today pick these
topics because I think they're they're
kind of demonstrating or they're
representative of where a lot of
activity is in this space and that's
bioengineering in microbial systems so
so there's been a lot of interest let's
say some hype certainly as well of
moving those pathways out of the plant
into a microbial potentially fermentable
system fermentation system to displace
the plant as a source of these products
and interestingly the first question
that was asked was not can we do that
instead the first question that I think
was asked in about 2015 was should we be
doing that is that is that something we
should be doing and you saw articles
appearing this was in nature I
questioned nature I questioned nature I
don't know if this is something that
would be referred to you know in the
u.s. these days is fake news but it's
it's interesting to kind of put that
spin on it right regulate home-brewed
opiates right you really want to start
didn't we go through all of this with
GMOs and plant transformation and so on
and now before the technology really
gets out of the door there's already you
know sort of a negative spin that's
that's put on it so I'm not going to
worry about that again it's something
that you know can be discussed is it
dangerous is the right thing to do I'm
going to just talk about science
and and show you what some of the
problems are what some of the good
things actually about putting these
pathways together in a heterologous
system is that you first of all learned
why it doesn't work very well and then
you have a new system that you can ask
new questions about and say what can we
discover to try to learn more about just
academically what we don't know about
how these these pathways actually
function despite the fact that we have
all the quote-unquote genes that are
that are involved in the pathway so the
first place I'm going to start is from
the group of christina smokey at
Stanford and they published a paper in
science in 2015 where they assembled the
the entire pathway and indeed they were
actually able to produce this the semi
synthetic hydrocodone de novo from a
cheap carbon source from sugar basically
it was a very substantial achievement
but the yields are telling you a story
it's telling telling us that we still
don't know um
certainly everything maybe maybe not as
much as we need to about how these
pathways function so what they got were
these levels of thei Bane and
hydrocodone so so sub microgram per
liter of hydrocodone what do you need
for commercial feasibility to make this
fermentation process competitive with
the plant with cultivating the plant you
need above five grams per liter so this
is more than 1 million times too low so
I'd like to show this diagram as a way
of reinforcing the the problem of scale
size does matter time so here's a cell
and here's a giant sequoia or a sperm
whale there's about a little less than
than 10 to the sixth difference in size
so we have to find a way of increasing
the yield in these engineered yeast
systems by a million times
that's the substantial difference in in
in amount for sure sighs all right so
the first story I'm going to tell is the
discovery of a new enzyme but that was
maybe suspected but not really sure
and call it fee Bain synthase so this
was published just a few months ago
earlier this year there were a number of
authors many of them came from in treks
on that we're partnered with um the
people in the company and my group that
are particularly instrumental in making
the discovery are Shui and and Jill and
what we noted so where this kind of
started was that this is the pathway
that I showed you over here so there's
salutary Dean reduced to salutary dnal
Isetta lated to seven Oh acetate and
then it was believed that the removal of
that Oh acetate that allylic eliminate
in it elimination is spontaneous and
certainly it is but in treks on when we
were working with them kept referring to
carbon loss the amount of carbon that
was getting to this point was much more
than the amount of carbon that was going
past it carbon just doesn't disappear
where was it going so it was Joel that
was looking at this and we eventually
discovered that there was a byproduct or
set of byproducts that was being made
alright so this this acetyl transferase
so we talked about sealed transferases a
lot today so this acetyl transferase is
not going to do what we want it to do
unless it has help and that and that's
because when this compound once that
acetyl group is is added to that
hydroxyl there this allylic elimination
is going to happen spontaneously but the
main products by far are going to be
these guys over here and what happens is
that water will come along and and
you'll have the oxidation of one of
these points over here so we're not
exactly sure which one we think it's
actually this one but it could
potentially be these other ones as well
these byproducts don't accumulate in the
plant we don't see them in the plant so
we we surmised that this is not actually
a spontaneous reaction that there's
something that's preventing this from
happening and instead promoting the
allylic elimination whereby this
hydroxyl rather than from water is
attacking this carbon over here and you
get Phoebe
all right so that that was a you know as
a deduction I guess continuing to look
at systems and not accepting the
literature as the truth but simply as as
a guide it's certainly incomplete and in
fact what we ended up finding was it is
an enzyme there's an enzyme that we
called thebaine synthesis and the way
that we found it was to take latex and
we assumed that it was going to be in
the latex because as these last steps
over here
I haven't haven't told you that but
these last steps in the pathway
especially beyond thebaine to morphine
are all taking place in that latex
whereas other steps in the pathway the
earlier steps are happening in adjacent
cell types we won't won't get into that
too much today but we decided to look in
the latex and when we took protein
extracts from latex and set up a coupled
enzyme assay weari added Sally tea
either plus or minus latex protein and
looked for what we made if there was no
latex protein we primarily made what
appears to be a collection of these
mass-to-charge 330 we just call it a 330
by product we make mostly that but when
we add in the latex protein we make
mostly c bang so we said there's an
enzyme in the latex that is catalyzing
that step it's not spontaneous so we set
about to purify it you go to the
literature what does the literature tell
us so the literature is telling us that
somebody's seen it before right it's
very hard to do something that you can
say I thought of this myself we we did
it was actually seen by Minard zenk and
reported a couple of times in the 90s
and in the mid mid 2000s and it was
saying look I we see something as well
they kind of got the byproduct wrong
they called it this as a neem
this thing over here we never see that
that part of it I think is is incorrect
but still the fact that there was
something in here that was coordinating
the formation of the-- bein as opposed
to a byproduct was was seeing or
suspected previously so we said about
two to purify from the latex and that
was done through a set of or through
using some classic chromatography
protein chromatography steps you know so
it so it's ammonium sulfate
precipitation and then hydrophobic
interaction I in exchange and then this
violent final one over here was was gel
filtration chromatography and the the
great thing now about protein
purification is in the old days you had
to actually bring the protein to purity
before you could subject it to amino
acid sequencing but now you can take
each one of these fractions and send it
for two hundred dollars for mass spec
analysis and you'll get back all your
proteins that are in that sample you
realize how impure everything really is
when when you look at things using mass
spec so we were able with just those
three purification steps to reduce the
candidate list to just five proteins and
those five proteins were then and and as
you can see there they were all fairly
related they were a low molecular weight
so only about fifteen killer Dalton's
fairly small and we expressed all of the
meaning coli and of the six that we
tested the first one here that annotated
as BET V one
it stands for betcha love vulgaris so
it's a type of so-called peer ten
pathogenesis related protein that was
first characterized in birch in white
birch and this guy the heterologous
protein was doing the same thing that
the latex was it was preventing the
formation of the byproducts and instead
coordinating the formation of Theban the
other ones weren't doing that so there
you go we had fiebing's synthase in
parallel you might have seen some of you
might have seen that the opium poppy
genome was reported from Ian Graham's
group just recently in the last couple
of months and we've done the genome
ourselves as well we have a paper that's
that's should be published hopefully
sometime early next year um on on our
version of the genome they're they're
pretty similar actually but one of the
things that we detected in parallel
doing the biochemistry was that there's
there's a cluster of enzymes and if you
remember the biosynthesis the rebbe the
reticulated him race and then the
subsequent one two steps cell salutary
and reductase and salutary team acetyl
transferase are clustered in the opium
poppy genome and you can see the
distance is they're not that far away
considering the genome is about 2.7
gigabase in size they're pretty close
and we also saw devein synthase there as
well we didn't know at the time that it
was but these things these two
approaches converged at almost the same
time and and gave us two parallel
streams of evidence for and and and
paths to discovery so i actually
recommend both right if you're you're
after things especially when you get
into the realm of I don't even know what
we're looking for
so what we try to try to take is a very
multi-faceted approach everything from
genomes to classic biochemistry and and
everything in between
okay alright so there's two genes for
--they bein synthase that we see in the
genome so bein synthase one and two
there's actually four proteins so one of
the genes the vein synthase one has a
secretion signal on it or a signal
peptide the other one doesn't we we
think that the first one is located
outside of the latex and the second one
the Thebans synthase 2 is soluble inside
the latex so I still don't know exactly
what's going on at the cellular level
but there's there's obviously a lot to
to investigate but then in addition to
that there is a cryptic start codon and
we have evidence both from transcript
size as well as by doing some additional
proteomics analysis that there is a
truncated form that that seems to
predominate in the latex of both the
veins
one and two and those truncated forms
and terminally truncated forms are
inactive still a lot to understand but
clearly I suspect that there's a role
for all of these things another system
that we use extensively and has worked
out quite well with opium poppy is a
functional genomics methods that is that
is based on post transcriptional gene
silencing so it's virus induced gene
silencing it's very easy to do so we
simply build a construct we infiltrate a
young seedling into the apical meristem
at about two weeks and by the time the
plants are 6 weeks old we harvest them
and and and test them and what you can
see here is that the knockdown of the
bane synthase transcript levels is
leading to a predicted decrease in
Theban accumulation and an increase in
salutary on all levels which is a an
upstream shortly upstream precursor of
the-- bane synthase in the pathway
interestingly we don't see a change in
morphine levels so morphine as the end
end of these pathways seems to be like a
sink it's just things eventually drain
down there and when you're looking at a
suppression technique like this you
don't necessarily see a difference in
the accumulation of these major end
products but you can see supporting
differences in the accumulation of
pathway intermediates that that give you
some physiological evidence that your
genes are correct they're actually
functioning in the plant the way that
that you see so this is this is what was
done there we silenced this we see
salutary and all going up and we see
the-- Bane going down and that that was
I think a good piece of evidence in
support of the role of the main synthase
in the pathway then in the context of
yeast engineering so how does this help
with the low titer of opiate production
in East so so what again this was done
in collaboration with and Trek's on so
putting the pathway together and and
either not having or adding pheeba in
synthase or the last one over here is
having everything integrated in the
genome of yeast
but also adding extra copies of the--
bane synthase transient transiently
expressed off of plasmid and you can see
that you get a substantial increase in
the yield of the-- bane compared to a
strain that is lacking the the-- bane
synthase it's just in this first
experiment it was about a twenty five
fold improvement so already we've gone
up you know an order of magnitude in in
yield in a very much not optimized
system these are the these are the tools
that are going to be needed to make
these technologies work and there's more
of these tools you're not you it's fine
you can have it a synthetic biologists
like to use lego a lot as a as a an
analog so you can have your bucket of
lego and you want to build you know the
Millennium Falcon if you don't have all
the parts you're not gonna maybe might
look kind of like it but it's not gonna
be what you would you want you need all
the parts so our job is to continue to
look for the parts and I think we're
pretty good at at finding them alright
so I'm just wanted to say a little bit
about localization so again you can see
proteomics analysis proteomics is
awesome I think these days it's really
superior in a lot of ways to looking at
transcriptomes so if we take latex and
then we take the rest of the stem that
has been drained of all latex we can see
in our proteomics analysis that the
entire pathway up to Sal R is pretty
much exclusively localized in the sieve
elements of the phloem and then and then
you have this transition zone between
Sal R and Thebe and at least the the--
Bains synthase to isoform so the Theban
synthase one is not at all in the latex
with that secretion signal and Thebans
synthase 2 is kind of split between both
and then by the time you get to the last
steps from converting see Bane to
morphine you end up with everything more
or less occurring in the in the latex
where the alkaloids accumulate so we're
discussing that a little bit this
morning that there's probably a role for
that Apple plastic space the cell wall
space between those two cell types that
is part of the metabolism it's not just
it's just
not a ride from one cell type to another
there's certainly more happening there
as well and we're not quite quite there
yet
okay I want to give you one more example
one more story before I'm done today and
it's again showing you how you can use
this system this the synthetic biology
if you know you want to refer to it that
way as a discovery platform it's not
just a an applied goal it it feeds back
on itself and it provides a new way of
looking at plant metabolism so here's
the problem again it's work that was
done in Christina's monkeys lab and
published in 2014 and basically they
were feeding a system working at the end
of that pathway
all right so they've got a system where
they've got T bein sick so D methylase
codon own reductase and and Cody no
demuth least EPS that are able to
convert see Bane to morphine and what
they got they got morphine but they they
also got this thing called neo morphine
Neil morphine doesn't occur in the plant
I'm gonna show you what the difference
is it's represented here but I'll show
you in just a sec what you don't want
Neil Murphy you want morphine so how do
you solve that problem they weren't able
to solve the problem with at least with
the available parts so we started
looking at this enzyme co2 known
reductase so so here's here's the
difference this shows you pretty well
the difference between neo morphine and
morphine or neo pain and codeine okay
they're they're isomers of each other
and you can see that the only difference
between coding and neo pain is the
position of that double bond right it's
here in neo pain not an improved drug
it's it's over there in codeine the same
thing with neo morphine it's it's over
here as opposed to here the plant
doesn't make these compounds maybe you
can detect a tiny bit of neo pain never
can you detect a neo morphine in the
plant or it certainly we haven't alright
so you can get to morphine via two row
or two routes you can either go through
six OD methylation first and then
reduction and then three OD methylation
or you can do three OD methylation first
and then 600d methylation second
and you in either way you get to you get
to morphine this the the pink route or
orange route over here is the major one
so we you know we thought well this step
over here seems to be key is codon own
reductase and this is this is one of the
observations that that we found so if we
put coding into a tube and added co2
known reductase or core and nadp+ so
it's a redox reaction we could detect
the formation of neo pain just by
incubating it for a few hours but it's a
reversible reaction theoretically if you
you know if you added neo pain does it
go back and the answer is no it doesn't
go backwards it will go this way but it
won't go backwards neo pain to neo
morphine or sorry neo piensan knee open
own is is not a reaction that is
supported by the enzyme so if li opener
neo morphine is produced from knee open
own or neo morphine all right so really
producing that that double bond over
there to an alcohol these compounds
become metabolically trapped the plant
isn't doing it but if you build this
pathway as it stands in yeast the yeast
do this and this equally how do you
solve that problem so we thought well
let's look at the part that we the parts
we already have and and what seemed key
in this process is this co Danone
reductase enzyme that is an NADPH
dependent reversible oxido reductase
enzyme there's quite a few isoforms in
any any particular opium poppy plant and
they're all very similar to one another
so this is a good lesson that when you
look at enzymes and you see that amount
of sequence identity you're probably
going to say well they're the same pick
one and and that can be dangerous
because they're not actually the same ok
so here's here's first indication that
they're not the same one of the isoforms
that we call Corby which only has a few
amino acid substitutions compared to
these core 1.12 four isoforms is much
better when it
provided with codeine and nadp+ at
producing neo pain then the other ones
are much better at doing it I very very
very much significantly a better a
better enzyme right so when we look at
its substrate range core there they're
actually very similar in terms of
substrate range and you know so they
must be participating somehow in in this
reaction over here so we thought okay
well how is it what's gonna happen if we
take core B as opposed to one of the
other core isoforms and put it in East
is is that our we are the engineers
simply not using the right
eisah form of this enzyme and certainly
there was a difference but the
difference was a quantitative difference
so here's core 1.3 that's not as good at
producing neo P and you can see it's
it's producing equally in a pathway
where we feed the Bain we've mimicked
what the smokey lab did we put the main
six OD methylase core either 1.3 or
Corby and we looked for for neo pain
versus codeine or we added in the
codeine OD methylase and we looked as
well for morphine and neo morphine and
what you can see is just as they
reported relatively equal levels of
either coding an EOP or morphine and neo
morphine a lot lower levels because the
co diem doesn't really work so well
Corby is doing it much better you can
see the scale is about 10 times higher
but it's preferring the formation of neo
pain there's something else going on
here
it didn't seem to be the ISO form of
core but we still follow this thought it
was it was worthwhile taking a look at
every amino acid substitution in those
isoforms and asking what do they do so
the paper the works being published in
plant journal and I'll just point out
that we identified four different
residues I'm only going to point out one
in particular it's that position 25 here
and it either exists as a valine or an
alanine and that one we're with that one
we're able to toggle between either the
superior conversion rate of
or be or the inferior conversion rate of
in this case core 1.2 or 1.4 we're able
to toggle between the two of them and
we're also we also saw that the
stability of the enzyme with a single
amino acid substitution is dramatically
changed so corby
is much more stable using this
fluorescence thermo shift assay it's
much more stable especially than core
1.2 1.2 was so unstable that we couldn't
even get a measurement 1.3 is not not as
thermostable as as as corby so you
simply increase the temperature and melt
the protein and if it's more stable it's
gonna melt at a higher temperature it's
just the basis of that assay so
something in it in response to even a
single amino acid substitution is
changing the stability of the protein
and its catalytic conversion rate
efficiency so taking this into a
structural realm we looked at a homology
model to model this after Chacoan
reductase modeled the enzyme after
Chalco and reductase and what the model
showed us was that this either valine or
alanine that one amino acid is
interacting sterically with the the
cofactor with nadp+ or NADPH so this
supports the mutagenesis work gives us a
lot of information about an enzyme in
the pathway but it doesn't tell us why
plants don't make neoprene or neo
morphine you know but you follow your
lines of inquiry we're collaborating
with a structural biologist in Calgary
Kenny and they've determined the the
structure based on the crystal of co2
known reductase it turns out it's dimer
it was reported in the literature when
it was first purified that it was a
monomer I didn't and and it's not the
structure shows us that it's a homo
dimer how does that change the way that
we look at the function of this enzyme
not sure yet but certainly you know
dimerization is going to change a lot of
the the enzymatic features of
of the protein so you know how does that
affect engineering strategies and so on
I mean more you know the easier things
are gonna be okay so I'm gonna go to my
last slide and just show you that we do
have a solution to this and here's the
here's some data in yeast when we add
when we use our solution I keep it quiet
because the lawyers told me um should be
shortly that it'll it'll be published
hopefully early next year and you can
see that we can do the same thing that
we did with the main synthase by
understanding how things actually work
we can change in yeast the ratio of
primarily neo pain and very little
codeine without our solution to
primarily codeine and and virtually no
neo pain with it all right so we think
this is how the plant is doing it
certainly it's a solution from an
engineering point of view and it's
applicable not only to the formation of
natural compounds but also to the
formation this is hydrocodone over here
as well sorry that not sure where that
guy came from but ok so you can read
about this hopefully in about two months
and find out what the solution is but
this is the summary slide of of
basically how we approach our basic
science and seamlessly more or less
integrated with the translational work
in the end the commercialization aspects
so we know there's lots of missing parts
still in the plant you need the plant to
find those missing parts if you're
working without plants and you're trying
to engineer plant pathways I don't think
you're going to get very far you can put
things together you can assemble them
you can use the assembly to do your
synthetic biology but then the synthetic
biology feeds back it tells us what's
not working tells us where the
bottlenecks are and we see many more and
when we identify a bottleneck now we
have a system that we can use to find a
solution and so far we've we've I think
done done quite well yields are going up
and and the trajectory looks looks good
in terms of hopefully at some point
getting getting too
commercially relevant yields not only
for this system but you could replace
this plant with anything you want the of
course the big one right now in Canada
is cannabis I don't even want to say the
word tired of hearing about it but but
anyway that's I'm going to stop there
and hopefully that was informative and
I'd be happy to answer any questions
this one already know so none of the
pathway is extracellular the products
have to be secreted to the medium they
won't accumulate in the cell so there's
going to be no storage capability within
yeast the the enzymes should be
localized to the compartments that you
know any signaling information on the
enzyme or lack thereof is is directing
so if they're p450s they're
membrane-bound so they're going to be on
the ER in the east if there are soluble
in the plant then plant cells then
they're going to be soluble in in in
East as well but ultimately the products
need to be exported to the media there's
nowhere to accumulate them piece pea
protoplasm equipment space at one point
to the east Qingdao so so that's that's
another one of the problems that you can
imagine is is going to afflict any of
these engineered systems is that these
these are kind of xenobiotic compounds
the East doesn't want them so pathway
intermediates are being kicked out as
well which you know if you're trying to
get to a specific end product you want
to keep those intermediates inside you
know so are their metabolic channels to
these enzymes in the plant interact with
one another are we missing helper
proteins components that are helping to
form those channels how does a plant
deal with many of these intermediates
that are
very hydrophobic not very water soluble
you know what to what extent are
lipophilic parts of a plant cell
involved in in biosynthesis these are
all these are all unknown questions but
questions that you know as I say are
emerging as as important because there's
a specific goal to to try to achieve and
problems to solve so don't you know we
actually don't know all that much more
than the model that I showed you this is
where these enzymes are found in two
different cells in the plant and you
know somehow there's a handoff between
those two cells of some intermediate
presumably I think the intermediate is
the Isetta lated the 7o acetate of
salutary and all because an acetate
would be much more soluble and easy to
transport from one cell to another see
Bane is highly insoluble it's very
difficult to get it dissolved even to do
an assay so I I'm not so sure that
that's a good candidate for trench
translocation how do these questions fit
into the efforts to try to do it all in
a single compartment in a single cell
we'll see don't don't don't know yet but
it works but it's not just a question of
having at work you have to have it work
well enough above a threshold to produce
levels that make it economically
competitive with simply throwing seeds
in the ground and growing plants still a
lot of questions we don't conference
said the morphine was in a frog so the
question is we have morphine in me well
us say so so there
in the last bits of research that that
he was doing that's that was a major
focus and it was demonstrating that in
human tissue that you can detect small
quantities of morphine the pathway my
understanding is that the proposed
pathway in mammals and and probably
other animals is chemically similar but
biochemically completely different so
there's no you know you can't go to the
human genome and find any of these plant
genes I mean you might find certain
things that are similar but they're not
functionally the same and they don't
participate in the pathway so it's still
kind of paradoxical and in the sense
that there seems to be pretty good
evidence that we make our own morphine
and maybe that's why we have such a good
opiate receptor or set of receptors but
there's still not very good biochemical
support that in terms of how it's done
how it happens we thought about that for
sure I thought we had an idea I mean
we're talking about this idea of where
two enzymes come from I mean if a pool
of of
of genes that can be recruited into
these specialized pathways
that's certainly that's the case I mean
we thought we had it solved a few years
ago and it was actually some of the work
that Scott Farrow did when he was in my
lab and it was it was looking at the
fact that these enzymes the OD
methylases
so the third to last and the last step
in morphing biosynthesis those OD methyl
aces will actually OD methylate a wide
collection of of benzyl isoquinoline
alkaloids with very different structures
than morphine and codeine and and what
we thought was oh that's the function
that's being selected for and this is
Joe
this is a not a byproduct but a parallel
thing that happens and it's it's
unimportant to the plant from a
selection point of view so so Scott
actually took so we thought well if
that's the case then we should find OD
methylation activity for orthologs in
plants that are related to opium poppy
and he looked at dozens of them and and
those those two OD methyl ethers are the
only two that showed any activity with
these benzyl isoquinoline alkaloids so
kind of threw that idea out the window
but I still kind of think that you know
we're always looking at this from the
point of view of morphine and look what
it does look at its pharmacological
activity there must be a deliberate
selection in the plant on the basis of
that pharmacological property and that
that can just be totally misleading us
it might be some other compounds where
you know morphine is just a you know a
happy circumstance of of some other
metabolism and and we're looking in the
wrong place for the evolutionary
connection but there isn't a good answer
to that I mean why does why does one
plant that's actually not true because
and we don't actually I'd like to tell
Health Canada this because I like to
cause them fits about how terrible
controlled substances regulations are
I'm sure it's the same in the US you
know we we started looking at other
related plants to opium poppy they're
not supposed to have morphine and about
half of them do the levels are much
lower but you know my what I like to
tell them is that you know a lot of
plants are on the verge of being able to
make morphine it doesn't you know how
much to what extent do you need
substitutions in order to turn enzymes
the key ones that are missing in other
plants that don't make opiates into
enzymes that can actually participate in
that pathway probably not many not many
substitutions so you know and when I
look at it that way I think well this
could also just be that we're in the
right place at the right time and we've
also been breeding this plant for 6,000
years so
you know we've changed a lot and that's
actually something we see in the genome
the genome of opium poppy is a mess just
like just like most domesticated plants
there's extensive copy number variation
there's all kinds of deleted bits and
you know I want to that's so
you know if you can find a backer we
need a we need a rich person that you
know cuz that would be great I mean
that's my that's my dream one day is
connect with anthropologists and have
this big international team go out and
find opium poppy material they that
ancient material and just sequence it
all put it against the reference genome
and see if you can trace how this plant
kind of moved around throughout history
I I think I think we could might even be
a science paper in nature need to I need
to do the yeast thing first and get rich
and then I'll do that I you know or or
take up a collection if you all want to
pitch in this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu